ND THE ASSASSINATI  TN TWO REIGI
N ED IN
THE RDCLUDINN ANIA
EXMILITARY.
T IN INVESTIGATI
MATT RIVERS REPORTS FROM
FOR THE FINAL SUSPECT
ASSASSINATION OF PRESIDENT
JOVENEL MOISE INTENSIFY        E
E  CIMEO
LI A A
AND THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THE
HAITIAN-AMERICANS. AUDIO RECORD
VE, GE THEMOMENT WHEN THE ASSASN
CEE RESIDENT
THE NIGHOF THE ATTACK.OFFICIALS
A SHOO ASSASSINSALL THAT REMAINT
BLIS IS ONE OF THE CARS THEYE S
AGED IOOTOUT WITH
.
OLVED AS WELL,
LEFTOVA RESULT OSHOOTOUT.
THE AFTEG THE
.
IN THEF JOVENEL MOISE'ER, THE P
MINISTER JUSYS O BE S  SAID HE E
SHOULDTHG E
URATION RIGHNOW. CSTN  CLEAR
I HAVE TO ORNI E PAS.
S EACHOUR
GOES BY, IT SEEM
GETTING NEW FOUSE SUCH AN EVOLV.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE'VE NOW
AST FORMER MEMBERS O
COLUMBIA'S MILITARY ACTUALLY ARE
THOUGHT TO HAVE BEEN TAKIN
IN ALL T TO THE
CLUM BEEIAING HEO HAITI THROUGH
PANAMAT  THROUGH
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
THAT'S INFORMATION
WE'RG.
THERE REMAINMO
TIONS LIKE WHAT WATHE
THIS KIL FIRST PLACE.
>> MATRSYO
LET'S  HAITI'S
ELECTIONS MINIST.R JOINING USRI
PRESIDENT MOISE.
WHO SH
-- RIGHTFUL PRIME MINISTEO SHOG
TO.
>> WE ARE OF THE GOVERNMENT
AND ACCORDING TOCONSTITUTION TH
VACANCY FOR ANY REASON, AS THE
MINISTER WHICH IS CLAUDE JOSEPH
IS IN CHARGECOUNTRY,
WITH THE S DO ECON
W THROUGH
WE ARE GOINGO DO.
>> SK CLAUDE J
THE RIGHT PRIME NIARIEED
JULY THE
THE SUPREME T LEADER WOULD RMAL
DIED RECENTLY OF COVID-19.
>> THIS ISOT
CASE FOR TO.
BUIFGOVERNMENT,
IF YOU WANT  INSTALL,
TYPICALLY IT'S THE
NI
E  WE
HAVE USETHN IN THE
THE CASE OF THE JUSTICES, IN
AL CONSTITN
BECOMEEALLY EA 120AYS
ORGANIZE ELECTIONS AS IS
Y AFTEETG THHENISTER, ANTHMPOSI
THAT'S WHAT WESTED
SUPPORT.
AND IC HELP, THEH E
HAITIAN PE A THE WLD.
THE SECOND IS TO
STILR THE COUNTRTOMOVE OE TH
THE DEATH OF THE
IN THET 0 DAYS. ON
HOPEFULLY ONCE DU AR AND YEARS H